esperando sencillamente que aquel año no pasara lo peor.
La mayoría de las organizaciones, sin embargo, limitaban su crecimiento
en el campo agrícola.
No podían asumir ese tipo de riesgo.
Estas organizaciones se volvieron nuestros clientes
y al combinar crédito y seguros, pueden ocurrir cosas interesantes.
Les contaré una historia más.
A principios de febrero de 2012 en el oeste de Kenia,
empezaron las lluvias, y lo hicieron tempranamente,
y cuando las lluvias empiezan temprano, los agricultores se entusiasman
porque por lo general eso significa que la temporada será buena.
Así que tomaron préstamos y plantaron.
En las siguientes 3 semanas, no cayó una sola gota de lluvia,
y los cultivos que habían germinado tan bien,
se marchitaron y murieron.
Habíamos asegurado los préstamos de una institución de microfinanzas
que había otorgado préstamos a unos 6000 agricultores en esa zona,
y los llamamos para decirles:
"Miren, sabemos lo de la sequía.
Los entendemos.
Les daremos 200 000 euros al final de la temporada".
Dijeron: "¡Eso es genial, pero será tarde!
¿Podrían darnos el dinero ahora?
Así los agricultores podrán volver a plantar
y tendrán una cosecha esta temporada".
Convencimos a los socios de nuestra compañía,
y más tarde ese abril, estos agricultores volvieron a plantar.
Tomamos, entonces,
esta idea de volver a plantar,
nos fuimos a una compañía de semillas y los convencimos de aplicar la prima
a cada bolsa de semilla.
Y en cada bolsa pusimos una tarjeta que tenía un número.
Cuando los agricultores las abrían, debían enviarnos un mensaje de texto
con este número, y ese número nos ayudaría a ubicar al agricultor
y a asignarle un píxel de satélite.
Un satélite mediría la lluvia durante las siguientes 3 semanas,
y de no llover, reemplazaríamos sus semillas.
Uno de los primeros...
(Aplausos)
Un momento, ¡no he terminado!
Uno de los primeros beneficiarios de esta garantía de replantación
fue Bosco Mwinyi.
Visitamos su granja más tarde aquel agosto
y desearía poder mostrarles la sonrisa que tenía en su rostro
cuando nos mostró su cosecha, porque reconfortó mi corazón
y me hizo dar cuenta de que vender seguros puede ser algo bueno.
¿Y saben qué? Él insistió que la cosecha, toda, saliera en la fotografía,
así que tuvimos que alejarnos mucho.
Los seguros garantizaron la cosecha aquella temporada,
y creo que hoy tenemos las herramientas para permitir a los agricultores africanos
tomar las riendas de su propio destino.
No más años de la copa.
En lugar de eso, espero que llegue, de alguna forma al menos,
el año del seguro, o el año de la gran cosecha.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)